hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast expanding surface plasmon
resonance capabilities with Reichert I'm
Christina Jewell of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
we're excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
today's webinar is sponsored by Reichert
Reichert technologies both a rich legacy
in developing and manufacturing robust
reliable and high quality optical
instruments spanning over a century the
life sciences division of Reichert
technology has brought this wealth of
knowledge and innovation to its surface
plasmon resonance product line Reichert
technologies life sciences addresses the
divert the diverse interests of
researches researchers in academia and
industry with extremely sensitive and
flexible SPR platforms before we begin I
would like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the green Q&A button located at the
lower left of the presentation window
and type your question into the box that
appears on the screen will answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation also please
notice that you will be viewing the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on a
screen icon located on the lower right
now if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the support button at the top right of
the presentation window or you may use
the Q&A but button to let us know that
you're having a problem if you can't
hear this presentation as I mentioned
just click on the support button at the
top right of the presentation window we
have two speakers for you today I would
now like to introduce them Philip Paige
PhD field application scientist
phil has over ten years of experience
working with advanced analytical
instrumentation and is published in many
peer-reviewed scientific journals his
PhD research focused on investigating
salt solute liquid and solute fluid
interactions at controlled pore glass
surfaces along with determining protein
behavior and dynamics in novel ionic
liquid solvents using spectroscopic
techniques phil is currently the field
application scientist for Reichert's
surface plasmon resonance spr product
line he works closely with customers to
develop a working protocol for their SPR
related research we also have Mary
Murphy PhD application scientist Mary is
an analytical chemist and a problem
solver with many years of experience in
perfecting instrumentation used in Life
Sciences Research her professional
background includes analytical research
and support in surface plasmon resonance
technology chromatin chromatography
electrochemistry microscopy and
spectroscopy Mary is a skilled analyst
with a concentration in both the
pharmaceutical and biotech field
she has considerable ability in method
development and troubleshooting you may
now start your presentation Thank You
Kristina for the very nice intro and
hello and welcome everyone and thank you
for attending our seminar on surface on
resonance so during this webinar we will
discuss the SPR phenomenon including its
theory and applications and then provide
examples of unique applications that can
be carried out on records SPR systems
so before we begin begin talking about
SPR I would like to just take a moment
to introduce Reichert and our legacy in
the design and manufacture of high
quality optical instruments records
heritage includes developing instruments
to determine refractive index
banning well over a century record has
over twenty years of experience in spr
instruments and applications in addition
our users have published their SPR work
and over 250 articles in various
peer-reviewed scientific journals
records SPR assistants cover the full
spectrum of biomolecular interactions
including protein protein and protein
nucleic acid with the sensitivity to
also investigate protein small molecule
interactions records spr systems also
have the added flexibility to handle
crude samples such as satellite seats
serum and particulates like whole cells
and bacteria liquor manufactures to core
SPR platforms a Tube channel and a 4
channel instrument both systems are
extremely sensitive and have the
performance to investigate very low
molecular weight molecules binding to
larger protein targets this high
sensitivity also gives increased
confidence in the data and allows a user
to work at low immobilization levels to
optimize data quality the systems also
maximize flexibility in terms of being
able to handle a variety of sample
compositions including crude sample
types such as cell lysates
serum and even whole cells the systems
can also accommodate a large number of
samples up to 768 samples for higher
throughput applications the systems are
also scalable to meet your research and
budget needs now and later and in
addition to offering these instruments
rhykker also has a variety of
professional services available to also
address your SPR and budget requirements
so now I will transition into briefly
describing how the SPR technique works
so to induce the surface plasmon
resonance phenomenon a wedge of
polarized light is passed through a high
index of refraction prism under total
internal reflection conditions in this
case we are using light from LEDs
operating at 780 nanometers in this case
all the illumination light is totally
reflected off the prison surface and the
reflected light is very intense across
the entire range of angles that is
visualized by the detector which is this
a photodiode array board an SPR a thin
film of an electrically conducting metal
is placed directly onto the prism in the
form of a metal coated glass chip this
metal is typically gold because it is
the most chemically inert metal that can
give an SPR signal in the visible
spectrum the polarized light impinges on
the gold chip at interface between two
widely different reflective indices the
gold chip and the medium above the chip
which is typically an aqueous buffer
what happens is an electric field
intensity or evanescent wave is created
as a life and pin jiz on the gold chip
surface this wave penetrates into the
gold surface and is absorbed by the free
energy electron density clouds of the
gold metal this interaction generates
oscillating electron density waves that
are bound to gold surface called plasmas
so what happens is when the momentum of
the incoming light matches that of these
plasmas we get resonance or energy
transfer and this resonance effect
causes a reduction
in the reflected light intensity with an
energy minimum occurring at a specific
residence angle this angle essentially
two changes and refractive index
occurring above the gold chip surface
and that palette technique gets the name
surface plasmon resonance or SPR now if
we envision tethering a biological
molecule such as an antibody to the gold
chip surface and then introducing its
binding partner the antigen the antigen
will bind to be mobilized antibody and
in turn cause a change in reflective
index this change or effective index
causes the residence angle middle bomb
to [ __ ] to a different angle that is
proportional to the mass of a
biomaterial on the gold chip surface in
the SPR instrument this angle change is
converted to a response and recorded as
a function of time known as a sensor
gram SPR instruments measure very
precise changes in refractive index or
mass at the surface of the sensor chip
the traditional unit of measure is micro
reflective index units or 1 times 10 to
the minus 6 reflective index units this
corresponds to change in mass at the
chip surface of 1 picogram per
millimeter squared so in essence what we
have is a very precise refractometer
that also is a very precise Ness sensor
the RMS noise level of record systems is
about point zero 5 micro riu or a mass
change equivalent to 50 dental grams
this high sensitivity enables the record
systems to monitor either low molecular
weight molecules or very few molecules
of higher molecular weights with
increased confidence
as PR can tell us many things about how
two molecules bind or interact simple
tasks can quickly determine whether or
not there is binding and rank the
relative dyeing level of many compounds
more complex experiments are able to
characterize rate constants or kinetics
the I'm Dion and operates of the
interaction in addition data from
experiments where responses reach a
study state is used to calculate the
binding affinity or equilibrium bonding
constant as PR can also be used to
determine concentration and
thermodynamic constants to understand
the mechanism that's driving the
interaction
so in summary spr is a very
information-rich technique that
quantifies the kinetics and affinity of
the interaction providing a
comprehensive characterization record
systems can quantify interactions within
and between the major classes of
biomolecules which include proteins
nucleic acids carbohydrates and lipids
with also having - civet e vector
systems can also probe interactions of
very low molecular weight compounds
binding to larger protein targets
furthermore record systems can also be
used to study interactions with whole
cells bacteria and viruses because of
records robot's fluidic design in
summary small molecules less than one
hour Dalton's binding for larger targets
such as proteins and proteins binding to
particulates like whole cells can all be
studied with the spr systems now we show
a example of our low volume flow cell
the image to the right shows the
placement of the censorship on the
instrument prism sensor chips are
available with a wide variety of surface
coatings including the industry standard
carboxymethyl dextran and planer chips
with carboxyl groups in a polyethylene
glycol background
the flow spell with a separate path for
each channel is then positioned and
locked over the center chip we have flow
cells for both two channel
and four channel SPR instruments the
flow cell is readily accessible and is
easily taken apart and cleaned in the
event of a plug the small volume and low
dead volume flow cell in combination
with high flow rates lends itself to the
measurement of fast kinetics our two
most popular sensor chips are the planar
carboxyl PEG chip and a chip with a
three-dimensional carboxymethyl dextran
service the planar chip was developed by
George Whitesides Whitesides group at
Harvard University it is a low capacity
chip which helps generate good kinetics
data the chip works well for 1,000 to
1,200 Dalton's peptide analyze enlarge
to very large biomolecules it is very
low nonspecific binding characteristics
due to the polyethylene glycol surface
coating to the right here the
carboxymethyl dextran chip has been used
in the majority of published spr studies
it is a flexible protective hydrophilic
matrix with large immobilization
capacity and works well for small
molecule analysis peptides and proteins
the surface also tends to resist
nonspecific binding next we also have
available a number of pretty derivatized
chips for instance streptavidin or
nutria evident is used to capture
biotinylated molecules and is a stable
capture a nickel nta chip is used to
capture his tagged proteins and tends to
result in a decaying surface
regeneration is with typically energy
DTA or emit at all
a planar hydrophobic surface is used to
capture lipids regeneration there is
with Champs a protein a surface is used
to capture ie G's regeneration is with
eh - glycine now we will transition into
some examples of data acquired on record
instruments example one will show
results from traditional experiments and
the antibody antigen experiment and an
enzyme binding to several small molecule
inhibitors examples two and three will
cover more unique applications involving
cell studies example four is the use of
a Rikard SPR in combination with mass
spectrometry example five is a lipizzans
peptide binding experiment so the first
and the first instance will look at a
traditional biomolecular interaction
analysis your anti HSA is coupled to a
planer and censorship using amine
coupling after EDC NHS activation on
both sample and reference channels the
antibody has flowed over the sample
channel only blocking is uncared out
using one molar ethanol amine pH 8.5
over both the sample and reference
channels on the right of the slide a
strip chart of six concentrations of HS
a were injected with regeneration using
10 millimolar glycine pH to the 10%
lists are all added the last injection
is a blank the final graph shows you
have normalized aligned in reference
subtracted time-dependent response
curves for the six different HSA
concentrations which range from 40 down
to 1.25 nana molar the red line is v to
a simple by molecular model as seen from
the data this assay fits very well to a
one-to-one model with a KD of about 6.6
nano molar
next we look at inhibitor binding to
small molecules for TDs and nothing
sulfonamide are binding to carboxy
benzene so far I'm sorry carbonic
anhydrase first we look at the binding
of four carboxy benzene sulfonamide a
two hundred thousand analyte to
immobilized enzyme in this instance
carbonic anhydrase was a mean coupled to
a carboxymethyl dextran ship via the
same procedure outlined for anti HS a
the normalized sample overlays are in
black and the model v is in red
each analyte concentration is injected
twice with the concentrations ranging
from 20 down to 2008 micromolar welfare
blanks were also injected in the data
was referenced double reference that is
both the reference channel and the
reference buffer blanks were subtracted
out global kinetic analysis of this
enzyme inhibitor pair yielded a KD of
809 nano molar since the data shown
reached equilibrium the equilibrium
dissociation constant was also obtained
from the Langmuir binding isotherm for
each injection we plot the average
response value at equilibrium of about
10 data points versus concentration the
KD from the Fed is 857 Danna molar which
agrees well with the kinetic result the
second example is the binding of the
same enzyme carbonic anhydrase to an
even smaller inhibitor methane
sulfonamide which is a con tiny Dalton
analyte this is a lower affinity
interaction with the KD from the
kinetics set of 652 micro molar and a KD
from the equilibrium set of 650 micro
molar so seen from the previous slides
records SPR systems excel at
investigating biomolecular interactions
the systems can also be used to study
whole cells this example right
as PR systems are used to investigate
cell adhesion kinetics this application
involves probing endothelial cells and
their interactions with common surfaces
that mimic human tissue specifically
this example is going to involve SPR to
probe the nature of endothelial cell
interactions with stromal type matrix
cell proteins collagen one and Facebook
membrane type protein matrix L so the
figure shows the vessel formation
process in vivo endothelial cells to
create basement membrane proteins such
as collagen four which creates a barrier
between the endothelial endothelial cell
and stromal tissue that are composed
mainly of structural proteins like
collagen 1 or collagen three when the
basement membrane becomes damaged or
thin due to injury and athelia cells
come in contact with stromal tissue and
blood vessel growth is initiated as
cells proliferate and local neason blood
vessels form
[Applause]
so this graph shows the interaction of
the different matrices being immobilized
onto the gold chip surface as well as
their interactions with the endothelial
cells so in the first 1,000 seconds of
the graph and basically the inset in the
upper left corner shows a blow-up of the
first thousand seconds of this of these
curves this is where the three different
matrices collagen one Matrixyl
and serum were mobilized onto the gold
shed surface as we can see that from the
plots that nature gel is immobilized
much faster and to a much larger extent
as compared to the other two proteins
this is mainly because of the favorable
electrostatic interactions between
Maitre gel and the carboxylated
Censorship surface after those matrices
were immobilized cells were pro fused
over the surface beginning at about a
thousand seconds as we can see upon the
profusion of the cells we see immediate
response from the collagen one surface
we can see we get a rapid increase in
response the response from a tree gel
and serum are much less as compared to
collagen so basically what this shows is
that differential solid heejun to
mobilize proteins can be correlated to
the protein surface energy in addition
proteins with higher surface energy have
greater tendency to bind cells like
collagen one in this case this slide
shows the actual optical images of the
optical images obtained off the gold
chip surface after the profusion of the
cells on the three different matrices as
we can see by the images we basically
have a very uniform and basically a
monolayer of cells on collagen one and
Maitre gel with more spotty coverage on
a serum surface
so next the research was taking a step
further and we wanted to investigate how
SPR can actually be used to sense hyper
osmolar shock in this case the cells
were challenged with a 100 millimolar
mannitol solution which is going to be
hypertonic as compared to the isotonic
piece buffer so as we can see upon the
initial injection of the mannitol
solution we see a very rapid decrease in
response for collagen 1 this decrease to
some extent is observed a matrix L and
basically is non-observant with the
serum surface
so this basically shows that and then
after the surfaces were subjected to the
mannitol solution we can see for
collagen 1 that the baseline starts to
return back to the same level but never
quite gets back to the original starting
point meaning that we did either have a
irreversible effect on the cells or we
might have shared some of the cells off
with the hypertonic solution so now we
look at the optical images after
challenging the surfaces with the
hypertonic mannitol solution as you can
see here the coverage is definitely less
most of the surfaces although collagen 1
still has a fairly dense cell coverage
we can see here that basically the
mannitol solution actually sheared off
some of the cells on the major gel and
basically most all of them on the serum
surface
so conclusions we can actually correlate
the increased by efficiency with
collagen one but basically the increased
amount of lewis acid and Lewis base
groups that are accessible to interact
with the endothelial cells and this is
basically the condition when the
endothelial endothelial cells actually
interact with a thermal tissue as the
under grow as the undergo blood cell or
blood vessel growth the major channel
surface has a much lower acid Lewis acid
and base groups and that correlates with
the reduced interaction with the
endothelial cells and this typically
occurs when the cells for model layers
on basement membranes so then we were
able to calculate the Young's modulus to
really determine the strength of the
adhesion in this case collagen has about
four fold higher banging origin strength
as compared to nature gel and these
results correlate very well with
previous measurements carried out with
atomic force microscopy or AFM we can
also conclude that SPR is a very useful
technique to probe cell matrix
interactions including both specific and
nonspecific adhesion systems these two
types of interactions are typically or
typically coexist in particular
biological contexts SPR is useful to
dissect intermolecular force
characteristics of solid fusion and
different metal systems especially at
short length and time scales typically
observe with SP honor in addition
hyperosmolar shock studies can be
carried out with SPR I'm really quantify
the strength of cell interactions with
proteins using SPR is a much much more
inexpensive simpler and easier technique
compared to other task methods and in
addition we obtain similar quantitative
results in comparison to AFM
next we'll look at protein binding to
live showgirls recombinant therapeutic
proteins introduced over 20 years ago
generate billions and revenue from a
variety of products for these
biopharmaceuticals showed rise cell
lines are the preferred host systems
because of their advantage in producing
complex therapeutics and manufacturing
adaptability for our SBR experiments
show cells were captured over Paleocene
at the first step poly l-lysine was a
mean coupled to a planar chip joke a1
cells were then captured a little over
the left channel only of a two channel
instrument the baseline increased by
about 644 micro refractive index units
next we looked at binding to fibrinogen
a series of 5 concentrations of
fibrinogen were injected ranging from
184 nanomolar up to 2.9 for micro molar
binding was carried out without
regeneration between each analyte
injections data was set to a mass
transport limited one to one dining
model and clamp the KT value obtained
was 62 plain for the animal er the
conclusions from our cell Biden studies
are as follows
results indicate that the measurement of
cell adhesion can be very easily
performed using a record SPR system in
general studies demonstrating ability to
pursue zwei cells and probe self-parking
interactions in a timescale of typical
SPR experiments record OCR systems
provide the means to obtain quantitative
measurements by enabling ready
manipulation of cell capture slowest
detachment kinetics other defined shear
stress and studies of osmotic pressure
purchase
in comparison to other competing
techniques like atomic force microscopy
spr measurements are more
straightforward and cost-effective and
the measurements reflect the behavior of
the average cell and the cell population
rather than just individual cells in the
next example example four we show how
spr can be used in combination with mass
spectrometry this pairing allows the
user to study kinetics and also to
determine the identity of what is
finding in a mixture the SPR is our
automated two channel model which can be
coupled to any mass spectrometer we have
a newly developed interface work on the
interface is been carried up by
Professor Michael Frizzle Keith group at
the signs I center for biomolecular
analysis and biomedical mass
spectrometry in Germany the coupling
schematic is shown here schematic
workflow of epitope and interaction
analysis using the online SPR ms epitope
analyzer is shown after the sample
injection item1 the analyte is captured
on the affinity chip item 2 followed by
the SPR chip item items for 3/4 kinetic
analysis of the affinity interaction
after sample processing through the
desalting interface items four and five
structural analysis is performed by ESI
electron spray ionization mass spec
total experiment time is about 70
minutes in our first model system we
look at her top part myoglobin or hhw
binding to the anti hhw HHM the online
ms s BRMS system is capable of detecting
and identifying the affinity interaction
of the myoglobin
anti-violent antibody pair in real-time
and the recorded spectra so a
recognition of
the able myoglobin SVR kinetic
evaluation of hollow myoglobin is shown
from online price processing which
yielded a KD of about 450 nanomolar
the total ion chromatogram shown here
shows a sharp pollution signal at around
five point three minutes the multiple
charge protonated molecular ions
identified the unfolded April protein
recognized by the antibodies the mass
spec used here is a Bricker esquire and
three thousand plus PSI mass back in our
second model system look at epitope
identification and affinity
determination of a beta specific
antibodies by online by our Jenna on
line SPR Emma's technique to identify
the epitope a beta auto antibody was
immobilized on a dextran SPR affinity
chip Anna triptych mixture of a beta
peptide fragments was injected
subsequent online desalting of analyte
prior to mass spec was performed after
illusion of affinity captured a beta
peptide which provided identification of
the a beta seventeen through twenty
eight epitope sub tied with a protonated
molecular mass of 1320 4.8 following
illusion of undigested a beta 1 through
40 through the microfluidic interface
SPR affinity determination revealed a
high affinity for the KD of about 3.5
nano molar in summary
with a combination of FCRA knapsack we
are able to do affinity buddies
biomarker evaluations identify protein
and peptide
epitopes we can also do precise antibody
affinity characterization and we can do
a direct label free antigen
quantification the final application
that we will discuss is a peptide
interaction with lipids ohms this work
was actually carried out by a group at
young punk University in South Korea and
the reference for the work is shown at
the bottom of the screen specifically
this application compares a newly
identified peptide base
phosphatidylserine indicator PSP one
with an axon 5 which is a common probe
for molecular imaging of a pathetic
cells so the first step in this work was
capturing the lipids ohms the vesicles
are actually extruded through a 100
meter filter our membrane prior to
flowing over the center chip surface and
this work a hydrophobic surface was used
which is basically metal sphingosine
covalently attached to a carboxyl
dextran surface the hydrophobic tails of
the final sphingosine extend out of the
vector and matrix and are accessible for
attachment to the lipids ohms by
capturing the lipids ohms in this way
the bilayer confirmation of a vesicle is
preserved as opposed to the vesicle
squashing into a monolayer so we
actually are studying the interaction
with the intact lip is all with the
bilayer conformation
after the Lucas ohms were captured on to
the center chip surface the proteins
were then injected in various
concentrations over the fossil tunnel
serine lipids ohms so we can see here
the kinetic results obtained for PSP 1 +
X + 5 the first observation that we can
see is the concentrations for PSP 1 are
about 100 full higher as compared to an
x + 5
in addition the Association radar on
rate is also faster for an X + 5 and PSP
1 and the overall KD or if a constant is
about a thousand fold higher for an x +
5 however we see main a pretty big
difference in the dissociation rates we
can see that for PSP 1 the dissociation
rate constant is about tenfold slower as
compared to an X + 5 and as it turns out
in other studies presented in this work
especially Sol studies it's shown that
actually PSP 1 is actually a better
inhibitor to the pH the circles and with
the SPR work it's really that the off
rate here is a major player and SPR
physically prefer met by looking at the
actual binding kinetics as opposed to
just looking at the overall bonyen
affinity so with that we would like to
conclude this webinar we thank you for
attending and further we encourage you
to also ask questions but prior to that
is why it's you i'm with the summary
slide and kind of talk a little bit
about liquor what liquor has to offer so
record wants to be your partner every
step of the way
record has top-notch customer service
and support solutions our systems also
maximize uptime that drives better
results
workers spr systems can solve your
research bottlenecks as we mentioned
before they're scalable to meet your
needs as well as your budget and they're
also accessible to your individual lab
the systems produce reliable and very
high-quality binding data with kinetics
concentration and thermodynamics we can
also help answer your questions
quantitatively the record systems also
increase your sample flexibility in
terms of being able to handle different
sample compositions like whole cells
cell life States and even serum so you
can do a lot more with the system than
just the routine interaction analysis
the systems also reduce your equipment
and maintenance costs with the robust
políticas EIN all the systems so thank
you again for your attention and we look
forward to addressing your questions
thank you for that presentation dr.
Murphy and dr. Paige we want to get
right to your questions and input so
here's a quick reminder how to let us
know what you have to say questions etc
can be submitted via the Q&A button at
the lower left we will try to get to all
of you but if not we'll be sure to
follow up with you after the broadcast
our first question is how do you compare
SPR to using other label-free techniques
such as ELISA sure so basically in
comparing SPR to other techniques such
as Eliza um we probably saw during the
presentation SPR basically followed the
bunny in real-time so SPR gives you the
actual time dependent binding curve
which basically reveals the binding
kinetics of the interaction a technique
like Eliza basically is an important
alysus that basically can kind of clue
you in to the binding affinity but does
not tell you anything about the binding
kinetics so SPR is a much more
information rich technique again to not
only reveal the binding affinity but
also actual budding kinetics
now what determines the implementation
of either a planner chip or a dextran
how did the analytes differ yes are
usually you choose the chip based on the
type of interaction you're looking at so
if you're looking at a protein-protein
interaction you might tend to use the
planar chip if you're using at a protein
small molecule type experiment you would
need to extra an in terms of in terms of
analytes so the main difference would
just be that if you need to look at a
small molecule interaction you would
need dextran for sure
how can you create different channels
for different analytes can they be
visualized by modifying the surface so
in this case what we're doing is the the
different channels are actually created
by the flow cell though so the flow
style is actually what determines the
politicals so we actually have you know
the two channel we have two separate
channels and then the 4 channel
instrument we actually have four
separate channels so typically one of
those channels they'll have to serve as
a reference or control so what the two
Channel instrument we basically have one
usable channel and with a four channel
we basically have three usable channels
so you can actually immobilize anaphor
channel different molecules at different
proteins wherever you're studying on
those three different channels and then
you can then I'll come in with the
analyte and flow that analyte over all
those channels in in series so now since
you don't have like you basically could
have one channel per label again that's
mobilized to the surface and then the
analyte can be injected either over one
channel or over all channels in series
where the cell images taken by a
microscope coupled to SPR
in this case the microscope was not
directly coupled but it was run you know
at the same time basically is when this
was done do you manufacture SPR chips
for other SPR instruments so currently
we have on we manufacture a actually
high to two channel systems basically
one is a manual or semi-automatic system
and the other one is an automated few
channel system and then we also have the
four channel system you know if you're
looking at you know higher throughput in
terms of chips we do manufacture that's
the subject ships textual surfaces that
go on top of the gold chip we actually
do and offer those through records so we
those tricks that Mary presented on you
know we do actually manufacture those at
record can SPR be used to study DNA and
RNA interaction certainly yes yeah SPR
is a very good technique to do that work
typically what you do is you work with
biotinylated
a DNA or RNA and you can actually
capture that very easily on a ship
evidence surface and of course of DNA is
very stable so regeneration and
conditions are usually not as critical
you know as with proteins so it's a very
kind of simplifies the experiment
someone so yeah it's very very doable
and very relatively easier experiment
could you explain how SPR calculate
Young's modulus
I think we'll have to take that one
offline we prefer handling that via
either direct contact or via email okay
great next question was the microscopic
view in real-time or separately on the
side from a different analysis it was
separately on the side but we do have a
photocell that could be used with this
this particular research was not done
with our photos oh okay but see we have
more questions coming in
let's see can you approach works for
analyzing complex samples sure yeah
that's one of the that's actually a very
big advantage that record offers is the
Systems Institute a very robust
political platform and deathless
fluidics platform can accommodate you
know crude or complex samples so you can
actually run you know satellite safes or
serum you know another kind of crude
samples across the gold ship without you
know having the risk of clogging
anything expensive so it's very doable
and also we can also you know as we
presented maybe a couple SPR to our
techniques license like mass spec and
actually identify what is actually
binding out of a complex mixture so you
can actually get fine information as
well as identification in one experiment
very good thank you so much dr. Phillip
page and dr. Mary Murphy for your
presentation do you have any final
comments for our audience we just want
to thank everybody for coming to our
presentation and hope that you have a
few minutes to fill out our poll that we
sent out thank you again now if we
weren't able to speak with you directly
today we'll be sure to follow up with
you we want to thank our presenters
today and we want to thank all of you
for joining us here at lab roots comm
we'd also like to thank Reichert for
sponsoring this live event
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing on our website through
August 14th 2017 we will let you know
when it's been posted and we hope that
you pass this information on to any
colleagues who
take in - who couldn't partake in
today's broadcast we hope to see you
next time bye-bye